make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob it's
been a while since we've done a beyond
omega level video and at long last
after countless requests most of them
coming from aaron wilder i'm finally
giving in
let it never be said that i am not a
benevolent ruler
of the rob core because today on beyond
omega level
we're covering resurrection man so
without further ado
let's get into his origin so
resurrection man was created by dan
abnett andy lanning and jackson geese
and first appeared in resurrection man
number one in 1997 and according to his
creators
resurrection man was based on a marvel
character called mr immortal who was a
member of the great lakes avengers which
is basically a comedy team filled with
characters that
their powers were honestly kind of
stupid but as his name suggests
mr immortal's power was simple he was
immortal he could be killed but every
time he died
he'd be involuntarily resurrected and
that's basically it that's his only
superpower
he has no other extraordinary abilities
whatsoever
and so adnan and laning realized that
immortality on its own
is a pretty terrible superpower to have
but it gave them an idea
for a new character to create which is
similar in concept to mr immortal but
with a twist
that makes him less useless so
resurrection man's real name is mitch
shelley who was a lawyer in south
carolina that actually had
mob connections because everyone knows
south carolina is a hot spot for mafia
activity but anyway a group simply known
as the lab
used mitch as an unwinning test subject
for technology they were developing
known as tektites which are basically
microscopic nanobots that heal
damaged cells the result of this
experimentation was that shelley lost
his memory
but gained the ability to resurrect
himself upon his death the twist that
abnet and lanning added to resurrection
man is that not only does he return to
life every time he dies but each time
he's resurrected he gains a new
superpower that is related
to the way he died now we would learn a
bit more about mitch's true nature
during his encounter with the phantom
stranger a being that's walked the earth
for millennia now while mitch is in a
comatose state
he's approached by the phantom stranger
who tells him that the two of them have
worked together over the course of many
lifetimes and that mitch is one of his
oldest friends suggesting that mitch is
much older than we originally thought
now the phantom stranger also reveals
that in the past
mitch would not resurrect but instead be
reincarnated as a completely new person
and did not gain new powers each time he
died as it turned out
those abilities were given to him by the
lad but before that
mitch was something much older and as he
reaches out into the astral plane he
recognizes the face of his longtime
nemesis
vandal savage now toward the end of its
first solo series it would be revealed
that while the source of mitch's
immortality is unknown
the lab that gave him his power of
instant resurrection and revolving
superpowers was working under the
direction of vandal savage now upon
realizing he possesses the ability to
resurrect with new powers
mitch wanders the earth trying to
remember his identity and how he
received his abilities
one of the few things he remembers is
that he was able to fly which is
something he finds out
mere seconds before being shot by some
gang members executing a drive by now
mitch also falls to his death but then
wakes up to realize
not only that he's alive but that now
instead of flight he possesses the
ability to manipulate the air around him
into a hard construct of sorts he uses
this ability to stop an out of control
semi
as a kareem's toward a diner while mitch
is trying to rescue the driver the truck
explodes killing him once again but then
he reawakens
this time possessing pyrokinesis and so
all those deaths and resurrections took
place within just one
issue resurrection man number one but in
the next issue we see a good example of
resurrection man's abilities
in relation to some more well-known dc
characters as he happens upon the
justice league as they battle the
supervillain amazo who's a giant android
with the ability to mimic the powers of
those he comes into contact
with now the justice league have their
hands full with amazon but resurrection
man gets involved in the battle
in order to help some bystanders and
also uses his pyrokinesis to cauterize a
wound suffered by the flash now when the
building that mitch is in
explodes he dies once again but this
time he comes back from the dead with
the ability to create powerful
explosions which he uses to blow amazo
apart
ending the battle and so this is an
impressive feat as amazo had been too
much for the combined forces of the
flash
green lantern martian manhunter wonder
woman and superman but even though it's
impressive
it does not really even come close to
being omega level and mitch himself
says as much in the aftermath remarking
that he isn't in the same league as the
heroes who are able to level cities and
save millions
while he only has as he describes it
budget superpowers so he has like the
sci-fi channel version of superpowers
right
now later mitch would encounter tommy
monahan better known as hitman who
decides that he's going to help mitch
take on the lab
by killing him repeatedly until he gets
a power that's strong
enough upon his resurrection we really
need to cover this guy's stories now
after several attempts where mitch comes
back to life with the ability to create
colorful butterflies
made of light or change colors like a
chameleon hitman is finally satisfied
when mitch gains the ability to
manipulate
cosmic energy along with a sort of
cosmic awareness now it could be argued
that resurrection man was bordering on
omega level at this point as he seemed
to be able to manipulate both energy and
matter on an atomic level and this shows
us why we can consider resurrection man
a beyond omega level character
because at any time he could be killed
and come back to life
with any power including those that
would make him a planetary or universal
threat the problem is he rarely keeps
those powers for very long and he dies a
lot because dying and coming back to
life with different powers
is kind of what makes his character
interesting now there would be other
instances where resurrection man could
be at or near omega level as well
such as the time he was subjected to the
reality warping abilities of a villain
known as schism which resulted in him
dying and gaining what he calls quantum
telekinesis which in practice
seems to be a form of reality warping in
fact mitch describes this ability by
saying that he feels like he can do
anything he wants and superman describes
his power as reality warping which leads
him to finding resurrection man
and bringing him in to help the justice
league defeat a villain called major
force who i believe was the same guy
that stuffed kyle rainer's girlfriend in
a refrigerator the guy was kind of a
dick now mitch helps them but ultimately
decides not to join the justice league
saying that the superhero life was
simply not for him and so
over the course of his history
resurrection man has had a variety of
powers
and it would really take too long to
list them here but everything from super
strength to energy absorption to super
speed to shape shifting to optic blast
if it's a superpower you can think of
he's probably had it but what makes him
potentially beyond omega level or at
least
definitely beyond omega level is the
possibility that at any time
he could resurrect with a power that has
devastating potential and that happened
on a couple of occasions when he gained
mana manipulation and reality warping
powers in the dc 1 million mini-series
a possible future was revealed where
mitch had a device known as the
resurrector
that allowed him to choose the power he
would have upon his resurrection
and in that instance he could definitely
be a beyond omega level character as he
could grant himself
all those powers at any point in time
keep in mind that it's not considered
incontinuity but should it never come to
pass resurrection man
would become one of the most powerful
characters in dc comics on a permanent
basis
instead of only for short stints when he
possessed matter manipulation and
reality warping before being killed
again but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an
end aaron wilder i hope you're happy
that you got a video on resurrection man
i mean god knows you actually got
a whole ton of members of the rob court
to rally to your side right like it was
kind of funny because i was i was
wondering how long
this was going to go on for and like
literally it wasn't
it stopped being just you asking for
resurrection man and it started being
groups of people
right like whole groups of people who
were like don't worry aaron wilder we're
gonna get robbed to do a video on
resurrection man so i hope you're happy
that you have it you managed to rally
the rob core to your side
and so i have done it uh for real for
true though it wasn't that i was
ignoring you it was just
i did so many different requests it's
really hard hard to fulfill them all so
uh here you go man your video on
resurrection man i hope you enjoyed it
i have no doubt that aaron wilder is
going to ask for more stuff
you guys always do i literally had a guy
who did that right he asked for a beyond
omega level video
i made a comment he was probably going
to ask for more stuff and he did
so uh as always
post your request down below in the
comments section uh but if you guys are
new here to comments explained
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob cork if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you